Jean-Paul II a bien concouru à mettre à
bat le communisme en Europe de l'Est
mais dans le même temps il a aussi
soutenu de tout son poids les dictatures
en Amérique latine quant aux questions
sociétales il aura surtout marqué par
ses prises de position ultra
conservatrice concernant l'avortement et
la lutte contre le sida voilà donc le
constat livré à l'instant par ce
documentaire tiré de la série les
coulisses de l'histoire et réalisé par
Christian Ratinet Cédric Condon et jean-
Yv Laour de quoi sérieusement terniir
l'image de liberté de modernité le plus
souvent laissé par Jean-Paul II nous
allons en débattre maintenant sur ce
plateau de débadoc en compagnie de mes
invités Gill feragu tout d'abord est
avec nous bienvenue bonjour vous êtes
maître de conférence en hisoire
contemporaine à l'université parisanire
spécialiste des relations
internationales notamment de ces aspects
religieux vous étiez le conseil
historique du documentaire que nous
venons de voir à l'instant consacré à
Jean-Paul II et votre dernier ouvrage
s'intitule otage une histoire de
l'Antiquité à nos jours et il est à
découvrir chez galimar Frédéric lemoil
est également avec nous
bienvenueoup vous êtes historien
spécialiste notamment du fascisme mais
aussi de la poputé et professeur au
lycée militaire de saint-sir l'école
vous êtes l'auteur de nombreux ouvrages
dont celui-ci c'est le dernier intitulé
les hommes de
publié chez Périn on pourra aussi citer
vous concernant pou un PAP pour la
France pou auquel vous allez bientôt
consacrer je crois une biographie c'est
prévu pour quand pour cette année
normalement pour cette année nor donc à
suivre Bernadette Sauvaget est ENF avec
nous bienvenue à vous vous êtes
journaliste spécialiste des questions
religieuses au quotidien Libération et
votre dernier livre s'intitule lui
l'affaire Ramadan sex et mensonges la
chute d'une icône publiée chez Fayard
euh Gill Ferragu je me tourne d'abord
vers vous c'est logique vous étiez
conseiller historique scientifique hein
sur le documentaire que nous donons de
voir et là il s'agit quand même d'aller
contre les idées préconçues c'est même
le thème de cette série les coulisses de
l'histoire il s'agit de de regarder de
plus près les idées préconçues qu'on
aurait de certains personnages
historiques c'est le cas avec ce film
pour Jean-Paul II euh il s'agissait de
rétablir une vérité c'est comme ça qu'il
faut comprendre les choses avec ce film
alors peut-être pas rétablir une vérité
je sais pas et c'est le le sens même du
du logo de la série il y a pas de vérité
en histoire mais d'essayer d'avoir une
vision peut-être alternative d'un pape
qui peut-être aussi a pas été
complètement compris et au-delà du cas
Jean-Paul II de comprendre finalement ce
que peut-être la modernité pour la
papotter qui n'est pas la modernité de
nos sociétés il y a une attente d'une
certaine forme de modernité dans toutes
les soci siété la papoté a choisi une
voix différente et c'était une tentative
de caractériser cette voix il y a un
consensus et c'est d'ailleurs dit
évidemment dans ce documentaire sur le
fait que Jean-Paul II a largement
contribué à mettre un terme au régime
communiste à l'est de l'Europe du temps
des deux blocs bien évidemment Michel
Gorbatchev a même reconnu que et a même
dit aurait même dit que ce n'était pas
lui le fausoyur du régime communiste
mais bel et bien Jean-Paul II hein on a
retrouvé ces phrases euh dans les
archives des renseignement soviétique
après la chute de l'Union soviétique en
en 1991 euh là-dessus il y a un vrai
consensus ah oui tout à fait là-dessus
bah Jean-Paul II est viscéralement
antiommuniste même si quand il commence
sa carrière euh jusqu'à lesvcher de
kracovi il passe finalement pour
quelqu'un d'assez modéré et les
autorités polonaises l'apprécient il est
envoyé par exemple lors du conclave
Vatican I euh du conclave lors du
concile Vatican I pendant toute la
période du concile il fait partie il est
le il il y a 17 évêces qui sont envoyés
sur les 64 évêces polonais il en fait
partie donc c'est quelqu'un qui jusque
dans les années 70 est vu comme un
modéré pas trop dangereux et même comme
un trait d'union entre le régime et
l'église et qui à partir des années 70
je veux utiliser un terme à la mode se
radicalise dans le sens antiommuniste la
suite de sa carrière jusqu'on son accès
à la Tiar puis par la suite son action à
peu près jusqu'en 89 91 c'est celle d'un
combattant vraiment contre le communiste
et à tous les niveaux ou Carol votila
c'est comme ça qui qu'il s'appelait dans
ses années 70 il était donc évêque puis
cardinal à kracovi tout à fait en
Pologne alors cette lutte anti
communiste auquel était vcéralement
attaché elle a pris une toute autre un
tout ha visage du côté de l'Amérique du
Sud et c'est le premier extrait de ce
documentaire selon lui l'église
latino-américaine est au bord du
[Applaudissements]
gouffre il pense qu'elle est en train de
devenir un cheval de troit du communisme
depuis qu'un grand nombre de prêtres a
rallé un courant progressiste baptisé la
théologie de la
libération
ils ont choisi de défendre les droits
des plus démunis pour lutter contre les
inégalités criante du
continent c'est donc un tout autre
visage au nom de cette lutte
anticommuniste qu'aurait offert
Jean-Paul I du côté de l'Amérique du
Sud la moitié de la population
d'Amérique du Sud est catholique était
catholique en tout cas à cette époque
que pensez-vous de cet extrait que nous
avons vu et cette euh voilà cette
première approche se versant peut-être
plus sombre de la politique
antiommuniste de Jean-Paul II alors un
aspect plus sombre je ne sais pas parce
que il faut bien rappeler ce qu'est la
théologie de la libération c'était une
vision politique menée portée par un
certain nombre de d'ecclésiastiques
parfois même au haut placés qui visait à
à s'engager dans le combat temporel euh
politique en adoptant une grille de
lecture marxiste contre la pauvreté
effectivement absolument abominable qui
ravageait ses ces sociétés et donc en
fait pour lutter contre les inégalités
vous avez une partie de l'église
d'Amérique latine qui considérait qu'il
fallait s'engager dans le combat
vraiment politique y compris pour
certains même les armes à la main en
s'engageant en s'engageant pardon dans
des dans des guirillas
armées tout cela pour et bien libérer
les les populations les plus pauvres des
structures sociales qui les qui les
oppressaient et donc en fait c'était une
vision extrêmement politique qui en fait
avait tendance à transformer Jésus en
une sorte de de révolutionnaire et un
peu à confondre si vous voulez le le
pauvre de l'Évangile et le et le
prolétaire de de Marx c'est-à-dire que
il il visait à à réconcilier ce que
l'Église avait séparé c'est-à-dire le
combat pour la justice sociale qu'on
trouve dans la doctrine sociale de
l'Église depuis le 19e siècle et puis le
l'analyse proprement marxiste où là on
avait donc une confusion qui aux yeux de
de Jean-Paul II la papoté était
inacceptable aussi bien sur le fond
politique et théologique mais également
sur le fait que ça risquait de fracturer
l'église d'Amérique latine parce qu'il y
avait bien sûr des courants qui étaient
complètement opposés à cette vision et
Jean-Paul II a toujours été très attaché
à l'unité de de l'église d'Amérique
d'Amérique latine bon donc discidence au
sein de l'Église catholique du côté de
l'Amérique du Sud inacceptable aux yeux
de Jean-Paul II c'est ce qui nous a dit
dit dans ce documentaire ce que vous
venez de nous dire pour autant a-t-il
fait le jeu des dictatures militaires en
place dans ces années 80 notamment en
Amérique du Sud c'est aussi ce qui est
dit dans ce documentaire pour en ne
reconnaissant pas les victimes de ces
dictatures alors le problème c'est que
les les archives que l'on commence à à
obtenir notamment du côté du côté
américain parce que les archives du
Vatican sont fermé pour ce pontificat
mais les entretiens que que les
responsables américains de
l'administration Rean ont avec les
responsables du Vatican en fait nous
nous prouve pas exactement nous montre
pas exactement cela euh je pense
notamment à des conversations avec le
cardinal Casaroli qui est le secrétaire
d'État de Jean-Paul II qui dit qui dit
très clairement au responsabl américains
que l'objectif de l'Église c'est bel et
bien l'établissement de démocratie en en
Amérique latine et il dit ça en plein
milieu des années 80 lorsque tout est
verrouillé par des dictatures militaires
extrêmement extrêmement violentes et
d'ailleurs le cardinal rajoute une vraie
démocratie c'est-à-dire aussi une
démocratie sociale c'estàd que Jean-Paul
II en fait faut jamais oublier ça
n'oublie pas le volet social il ne
valide pas les systèmes d'inégalité
social et encore moins le capitalisme
néolibéral de Ronald Rean encore moins
en en Amérique latine c'est un pas
d'équilibre y compris dans sa gestion de
la théologie de la libération on va voir
ce qu'en pense Bernadette souvaget oui
enfin je pense que on peut ça dépend de
quel point de vue on se place qui divise
l'Église catholique enfin euh enfin
voilà je veux dire on sait pas si c'est
si c'est ceux qui soutiennent les
dictatures latino-américaines ou si ceux
qui qui essayent de de de de combattre
la la la pauvreté quoi enfin je veux
dire qui sont les diviseurs et qui sont
et qui sont les les les rassembleurs je
crois que en fait il y a quand même
plusieurs voilà on va pas rentrer dans
les détails mais il y a plusieurs
théologiens de la Libération il y a
plusieurs théologies de la Libération et
il y a plusieurs leaders de de la
théologie de la libération euh
effectivement par ce qui semble à qui
c'est que Jean-Paul i n'a jamais rendu
officiellement hommage aux victimes de
ces dictatures et c'est ce qu'on lui
reproche après coup oui enfin même aussi
euh il y a l'action de de son de son de
ce qui a été son secrétaire d'État le
cardinal Sodano qui est non apostolique
au Chili qui va combattre l'Église
officielle chilienne qui est l'une des
des des des forces d'opposition à la
dictature de de pinoché je pense que le
le le le le panorama est peut-être plus
complexe que que que que simplement
marxiste contre non marxiste et cetera
enfin l'église chilienne va
combattre va combattre le régime de
pinoché et le nom sapostolique le
cardinal saudano va combattre cette
cette église officielle alors Gill
feragu faut assumer là hein alors tout à
fait effectivement on a tendance à lire
cette situation d'un point de vue guerre
froide c'est-à-dire soit il est contre
le marxisme soit il est pour le marxisme
or et c'est ce que vient de rapporter
c'est ce que vient de de rappeler mon
collègue Jean-Paul II c'est aussi celui
qui avec une encyclique qui s'appelle
santesyousanous revient sur toute la
doctrine sociale de l'Église il a lui
aussi un projet social qui est celui de
son prédécesseur Léon XI qui est un
projet qui ne ressemble pas au projet
social américain fondé sur libéralisme
qui ressemble pas non plus au projet
social marxiste qui est un projet
spécifiquement catholique et je pense
que c'est ce qui n'est pas c'est ce on
ne comprend pas toujours c'est le pape
qui veut revenir aux valeurs du
catholicisme et à un catholicisme qui
est finalement celui du 19e et du début
du 20e avec en profitant de
l'adornamento qui a été celui du concile
donc ni russe ni soviétique ni américain
Vatican c'est un pape aussi qui se sera
beaucoup appuyé sur les les méthodes de
renseignement et S et semble-t-il c'est
beaucoup impliqué dans ce domaine du du
du renseignement à cette époque vous
évoquiez ran puisque effectivement c'est
la grande période de de de Ronald Rean
mais semble-t-il que les renseignement
américains on ont très étroitement
collaboré concernant les régimes que
nous avons évoqué alors effectivement à
la fois en Europe de l'Est bien entendu
et du côté de l'Amérique latine euh pour
contrecarrer ces initiatives euh
communistes ou socialiste
marxisante du côté de l'Amérique du Sud
vous faites référence par exemple là au
aux archives américaines vous faites ça
prouve ça TS à prouver tout de même que
cette collaboration à l'époque était
très forte concernant les régimes évoqué
elle est très très forte alors il n'y a
pas d'alliance parce que les mots on un
sens hein il n'y a pas d'alliance entre
le Vatican et les États-Unis il y a une
relation spéciale qui s'établit autour
de ces deux formidables personnalités
qui ont é Rean et Jean-Paul i tous les
deux ont été acteurs tous les deux ont
failli mourir dans un attentat et les
deux en ont tiré la conclusion que s'ils
ont survécu c'est parce qu'ils ont une
mission et que cette mission
effectivement bah c'est d'abattre euh
c'est les les régimes les tyrannies
communistes et cette collaboration en
effet bon elle se fait autour de l'idée
que don en effet il faut combattre le
communisme le projet de Rean est il l'a
résumé à à une formule à la à la Rane
euh nous gagnons ils perdent et donc
cette relation spéciale elle s'est
fondée effectivement sur des échanges de
renseignement il y a beaucoup d'argent
aussi qui a circulé hein par la CIA qui
est allé aider à financer le
solidarnosque en en en Pologne mais
c'est surtout des des informations qui
ont été transmises des images
satellitaires des informations de la CIA
par les États-Unis notamment en 81
lorsque la situation polonaise est
dramatique que le pays est à deux doigts
d'être envahi par les Soviétiques et on
sait que au Vatican Jean-Paul II a reçu
des informations très précises sur la
concentration des forces soviétiques qui
s'apprêtaient à à déferler sur sur la
Pologne
et le le le l'élément important c'est
que on considère souvent que c'est c'est
la présence de Jean-Paul II sur le trône
de Saint-Pierre qui a arrêté BR nef dans
le dans l'invasion même si a sans doute
eu aussi d'autres raisons et j'ai lu
quelque part que Jean-Paul i recevait
personnellement le le patron de la CIA
de l'époque oui et qui est catholique
Rean est entouré catholique c'était pas
l'usage habitué du côté de du Vatican
vous souhatiez réagir oui juste en fait
le l'utilisation par les États-Unis de
des des forces religieuses elle se
limite pas dans cette affaire là
au Vatican et à Jean-Paul II il se
servent aussi des des mouvements
évangéliques et notamment des mouvements
pandcotistes qui vont fortement
développé en Amérique latine pour
contrer les les projets les les les
eschatologies politiques du marxisme
mais également aussi dans un autre lieu
qui est très important de de cette
guerre c'est la la la Corée du Sud qui
en en 30 40 ans va devenir la grande
nation prentecotiste évangélique en fait
c'est pour ça que dans la stratégie
américaine la la religion est quelque
chose qui qui sert à à contrer àer le le
marxisme à contrer le le communisme conu
les islamistes on va regarder rajouter
quelque chose très significativement
rigane est le premier président à
envoyer un ambassadeur auprès du
saintciè jusque là il y en avait pas eu
les États-Unis se l'interdisaient ran va
envoyer un ambassadeur ça aussi c'est un
signe fort quand même de lire on va voir
un deuxième extrait du du documentaire
cette fois le mur est tombé nous sommes
en 1900 91 et jean-pa i retourne en
Pologne sous un ciel qui tourne à
l'orage Jean-Paul i prend position sur
une question qui divise profondément la
société
polonaise
l'avortement avec le même sens de la
provocation qui avait fait des miracles
contre le régime communiste il rapproche
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et la
[Musique]
Choa tego
cmentarzystka ofiar
ludzkiegoeństwa W naszym
stuleciu dołącza się Inny jeszcze wielki
C cmentarz
nienarodzon alors ce qui est dit dans ce
documentaire c'est qu'à l'époque les
banderoles ne sont plus de m en
référence à ce qu' a été sa première
éidemment visite en Pologne sous le
régime communiste n'ayez pas peur
évidment cette fameuse phase devant les
les les Polonais réunis à kracoville
mais là les temps change est-ce que ce
n'est pas à partir de cette chute du mur
et sur ces thèmes sociétaux notamment
celui de l'avortement que l'étoile de
Jean-Paul II commence à PIR il est vrai
qu'il y a une attente on attend
maintenant Jean-Paul II entre guillemets
au tournant sur ce qu'il va faire après
avoir été c'est c'est sensible dès ce
moment-là l'un des artisans de la chuite
du mur mais l'idée de Jean-Paul II toute
sa politique c'est de revenir finalement
aux fondamentaux des valeurs catholiques
et la lutte contre l'avortement fait
partie de ces fondamentaux c'est-à-dire
que il ne fait pas ce qu'on attend de
lui c'estàdire le pape qui va aller
au-delà d'un discours déjà libéral il
est au contraire le pape qui revient à
aux questions traditionnelles et à la
position traditionnelle de l'église
là-dedans on peut pas lui demander de
pas être catholique c'est à peu près ça
le le problème qui de là comparé
l'avortement à la Choa qui plus est en
terre polonaise alors ça c'est une
stratégie il y a il y a au moins un côté
très provocateur là c'est donc c'est une
stratégie une stratégie de communication
c'est vrai qu'il parle d'une culture de
mort pour parler de l'avortement mais et
ça lui a été énormément reproché c'est
un vrai débat c'est son parallèle entre
l'avortement l'histoire du peuple
polonais et la choix et ça va être une
manière on va l'accuser de christianiser
notamment la choix enfin le mélange
entre les trois choses est un élément de
sa
communication et c'est aussi un élément
de sa personnalité c'est le pape
polonais est-il Vic ement différent de
ses
prédécesseurs et de ses successeurs
d'une certaine manière sur ces questions
de l'avortement non il y a une
permanence et il y a une permanence chez
lui puisque dès les années 60 sa
position est est très très claire il a
été l'un de ceux qui ont convaincu Paul
6 à ne pas valider la contraception
chimique en 1968 donc il y a chez lui
une vraie cohérence alors bien sûr dans
la première partie du pontificat la les
questions internationales de guerre
froide ont pris ont pris le dessus et
après c'est c'est c'est vraiment arrivé
sur le devant de la scène d'autant plus
que effectivement la Pologne se
libéralisant s'ouvrant à l'Occident bien
vous avez l'influence évidemment des
évolutions sociétales en Occident qui
commencent à toucher les pays d'Europe
de l'Est et ça il ne l'a effectivement
jamais accepté et comme le dit très bien
mon collègue on peut pas demander au
pape de de valider l'avortement d'autant
plus que pour Jean-Paul II dans dans sa
tête il faut bien comprendre que écrire
une biographie d'un PAP c'est
extrêmement difficile parce que ce sont
des êtres humains bien évidemment mais
mais qui vit dans un univers qui est
tout à fait particulier et pour lui il n
a pas incohérence dans son combat
puisque le combat pour les droits de
l'homme concerne l'enfant en être aussi
pour lui il n a il n'y a pas de
différence dans sa dans son esprit je
juste voulais compléter enfin on peut
pas il y a la question de de
l'avortement et la question de la
consception enfin il y a pas il y a pas
il y a pas équivalence aussi la question
d'un d'un second politique à trouver
après cette chute du mur et il a éé
essayé de la trouver sur ses questions
sociétales et
oui tout à l'heure je moi je crois pas
que ce soit qu'il essaie de retrouver un
discours je pense que c'est son discours
c'est son discours depuis le enfin
depuis tout le jour enfin c'est son
discours de de responsable catholique je
veux dire la grande période politique de
de de Jean-Paul II effectivement
s'achève avec la la la la chute du mur
et là il va être sur le le
réarmement éthique de de de l'Église
catholique enfin de de de de fonder de
de fonder avec force ce qu'il considèr
être l'identité catholique mais en ce
qui concerne l'avortement effectivement
c'est un nœud un nœud indémêlable un
nœud important un gordien de de de la
rupture entre l'Église catholique et la
modernité et qui qui court et qui
court inclusivement si je veux dire si
je peux dire avec le Pape François le
pape François soi euh qui qui est
apprécié pour des tas de par par une
opinion une large opinion public en
dehors des des cercles au-delà des
cercles catholiques est également un un
grand profondeur de de de l'avortement
enfin là il y a une constante tout au
long après la Seconde Guerre mondiale
des papotés successives sur cette
question là là c'est sur cette question
là c'est c'est une espèce de de nom
catégorique des des papotés successives
et y compris avec avec François alors
autant peut-être cette prise de position
concernant ce thème de l'avortement
était peut-être prévisible c'est un peu
ce que vous venez de nous dire autant
celle prise plus tard lors d'une visite
en Ouganda concernant cette fois le sida
et sans doute plus embêtante extrait
dernier extrait du
documentaire alors que le préservatif
est le seul moyen de prévention du sida
il le condamne
systématiquement
[Musique]
en 1993 àampala la capitale andaise où
25% des habitants sontéropositifs le
Saint-Père
déclare la chasteté est l'unique façon
sûre et vertueuse de mettre fin à la
plie tragique du
sida en ouanda à l'époque 25% de la
population souffre du sida est-ce que là
nous ne sommes pas face à un pape qui va
contre qui est réellement à
contrecourant de l'évolution de la
société avec cette question est-ce que
là là pour le coup le documentaire ne
met pas le doigt sur sur quelque chose
qui qui est avéré finalement c'estàdire
qu'il s'est peut-être trompé sur cette
position en tout cas à l'époque ça té
général hein t les générale cette
position ça fait un scandale absolu euh
et légitime euh est-ce qu'il est à
cont-temps de son époque peut-être
est-ce qu'il est à cont-etemps de sa
doctrine non non il prêche finalement
enfin c'est ce qu'on voyait tout à
l'heure il prêche la solution qui est la
solution catholique à cette question à
savoir
l'abstinence après encore une fois
évidemment il y a une attente de la
population qui est terrible notamment
pour cette questionl euh il est dans son
rôle et c'est aussi même s'il a une
forme
d'incompréhension je pense que le Paris
qui est fait c'est peut-être retenir
ramener moins de de croyants vers
l'église mais ce que ce qu'il va ramener
euh ce sont de vrais fidèles convaincus
justement de ce discours même si ce
discours est en décalage avec la
modernité des sociétés
oui une précision il appelle à la à la
chasteté la chasteté ce n'est pas la
continence c'estàd l'absence de
relations sexuellees la chasteté c'est
les relations sexuelles dans le cadre
défini par l'Église catholique qui est
le cadre du mariage qui est un sacrement
religieux donc effectivement il défend
la doctrine de surtout il n'appelle pas
à porter préservatif pour émiter les mil
les millions de morts auquel nous avons
assisté dans ces années-là avec cette
cette oui bien sûr bien sûr mais comme
je le disais il faut être dans la tête
ce qui est toujours compliqué du du pape
c'est-à-dire que pour lui valider
l'usage du préservatif c'est valider la
pluralité des relations sexuelles ce qui
va à l'encontre absolue totale de la
doctrine catholique sur le mariage donc
il défend il est pape il défend la
doctrine catholique
ou non je pense que c'estitf cette
séquence là est une tragédie est une
tragédie absolue et pour l'Église
catholique et et et pour Jean-Paul
II juste effectivement il défend la
doctrine mais il ne défend pas la vie
alors qu'il défend la vie en disant
qu'il est contre l'avortement donc
peut-être que la logique aurait été de
de défendre la vie aussi puisque la
chasteté entre il y a des il y avait des
époux qui étaient contaminésf je veux
dire le le la la question que ça se
passe en dans dans dans un couple marié
voilà ne résout pas le ne résout pas le
problème je pense que effectivement
cette séquence et celle aussi qui sera
celle de de Benoît 16 quelques années
plus tard sont des tragédies sont des
tragédies en terme d'opinion publique et
en terme de compréhension aussi et de et
d'attitude de de de de bienveillance
vis-à-vis des des des des société enfin
je veux dire la rigidité enfin la la la
réaffirmation comme ça de la d'une
rigidité de de de doctrine et et
effectivement enfin on peut poser la
question de où est la défense de la vie
là
quoi c'est la question finalement du
rôle de l'Église qu'est-ce qu'on attend
de l'église est-ce que l'Église je vais
être provocateur mais est-ce que c'est
le pharmacien qui vous conseille un
médicament ou est-ce que c'est entre
guillemets le directeur de conscience
qui vous propose une position même si
celle-là est difficile et le le choix
qui est fait par Jean-Paul I à ce
moment-là c'est d'être le directeur de
conscience et de s'exposer à ce choix
difficile alors bien évidemment ce n'est
pas la culture de vie en tout cas c'est
pas celle que l'on attend ça montre à la
fois le décalage qui peut y avoir entre
nos sociétés et l'église et en même
temps le rôle qu'on attribue à l'Église
qui est celui de préserver une culture
un système de valeur on y a on y croit
ou pas et un une une certaine forme de
morale c'est ce qu'il fait finalement il
en quelque sorte il défend ce qu'on
appelle la loi naturelle
et cette loi naturelle elle vient de
l'Évangile et
euh ne peut pas le pape ne peut pas
aller à l'encontre euh de l'Évangile et
de la tradition de de l'église sur cette
sur cette question il faut aussi
rappeler bien sûr qu'il a aussi eu des
gestes importants vis-à-vis des malades
des malades du sida il n'y a pas part du
pape une
indifférence vis-à-vis de cette épidémie
qui à l'époque était absolument
terrifiante euh il défend on rappelle
que le pape François
lui lorsqu'il était bunosire évc
cardinal hein du côté se mettait à genou
pour laver les pieds
les des victimes du du du sida
c'estàdire que là on a on a deux papes
tout de même qui semble avoir une
approche radicalement différente de
sur ce sujet par exemple il rejetait les
malad du sida non il n'a jamais eu de la
part du pape un rejet du malade du sida
absolument pas il y a une défense de la
doctrine catholique sur le mariage et la
sexualité PAP pas on peut pas comme mon
collègue l'a dit on peut pas demander au
pape de ne plus être catholique alors
autre sujet on ne peut plus sensible au
sein de l'Église catholique ce sont les
crimes de pédocriminalité euh il est
évoqué dans ce documentaire le cas du
cardinal Bernard Law du côté des
États-Unis que Jean-Paul II aurait à
couvert semble-t-il hein c'était plutôt
à la fin de son pontificat il était déjà
assez affaibli physiquement Paul i Il
exfiltre ce cardinal américain au
Vatican de telle manière à lui éviter
des poursuites judiciaires du côté des
des États-Unis et puis on a appris plus
récemment qu'une par le biais d'une
enquête réalisée par une télévision
privée polonaise que lui-même aurait
couvert hein du temps de sa du temps
dans son diocèse à kracovi un certain
nombre d'actes de pédocriminalité au
sein de ce ce même diocèse et avec des
éléments des témoignages qui ont été
apportés par cette enquête réalisée par
une une une télévision euh polonaise ça
date de de de quelques mois la diffusion
de de cette enquête sur cette question
de la pédocriminalité au sein de
l'Église catholique il n'aa pas été un
précurseur c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire non plus c'est ce qui lui est
reproché en tout cas à la toute fin de
ce film est-ce qu'on peut dire les
choses comme ça moi je crois
effectivement ça c'est un des grands
loupés entre guillemets de de ce
pontificat enfin on parle de Bernard lou
mais il y a une affaire encore plus
grave et encore plus emblématique c'est
le celle de Marcelo Maciel fondateur des
Légionnaires du Christ hein qui l' qui
l' protégé y compris contre successeur
son successeur le cardinal Ringer qui
voulait régler la question du du de
Marcelo Maciel Maciel est un ENF dans au
sein de l'Église catholique un un des
grand prédateur sexuel un des grands
criminels sexuels de de l'Église
catholique cardinal ratinger qui
deviendra Benois 16 absolument voilà qui
qui à ce moment-là le le le bras droit
de de de Jean-Paul I qui lui souhaite
régler la question de de de Marcel Mael
et jusqu'au bout jusqu'à la fin
Jean-Paul II va va défendre protéger
Marcelo Maciel donc en fait
effectivement Jean-Paul II pour lui ce
n'est pas une question en fait hein il a
cette idée que il vient d'unun d'un
monde où on fait des compromates les
fameux enfin les
fameux moyen de compromettre enfin les
le système soviétique qui met en place
des des des des fausses informations
pour compromettre des des opposants et
notamment des prêtres catholiques qu'on
attaque souvent sur des problèmes de
Merce donc il est dans cette logique en
fait on attaque l'église à travers ça
enfin il y a pendant 20 ans enfin
l'Église catholique va tenir ce discours
en fait ceux qui sortent ces affairesl
ce sont des ennemis de l'église et les
ennemis enfin ils veulent abattre
l'église en en en en parlant de ces de
ces affaires là il est très sur cette
sur
cette sur cette ligne mais mais mais
c'est une enfin elle est dans la logique
de la de de de de
l'homme du radical du du du PAP radical
là-dessus enfin il veut défendre envers
et contre tout son son institution
quitte quitte à la mettre au bord du à
la mettre au bord du gouffre finalement
c'est notamment financier avec les
États-Unis en tout cas il n'aura pas
anticipé le problème que la ça allait
susciter et que ça suscite aujourd'hui
au sein de il est même allé jusqu'à le
nier enfin à le ni et à le couvrir enfin
l'affaire de de Marcelo Maciel je trouve
est très emblématique de l'attitude de
de de Jean-Paul II il couvre
délibérément il protège délibérément
Marcelo Maciel ouis je vais rappeler les
chiffres concernant la France
oui l'Église catholique en France tiré
du du fameux rapport de Jean-Marc Sauvé
hein qui a dirigé la commission
indépendante de sur les abus sexuels
dans l'Église catholique qui estimé à
216000 personnes le nombre de victimes
en 70 dis an euh d'actes de
pédocriminalité au sein de l'Église
catholique un chiffre qui va jusqu'à
330000 personnes victimes si on y ajoute
le personnel des établissements
scolaires de catéchisme les encadrants
de mouvement de jeunesse il n'aura pas
anticipé ce qui est aujourd'hui une des
crises majeures un des problèmes majeurs
à régler au sein même de l'Église
catholique clairement il a pas du tout
anticipé euh au moment où vous donniez
ces ces chiffres moi je pensais au
chiffres d'affaires qui avaient été
examiné euh par les église directement
entre 2002 et 2009 il en a 300
c'est-à-dire qu'il y en a moins que par
exemple dans le seul diocèse de Boston
dont on parlait tout à l'heure où à la
même époque il y a au moins 450 plaintes
donc effectivement il y a là pour le
coup une erreur et de communication et
même de de management qui est qui est
importante et qui questionne là encore
une fois il s'agit pas de juger mais de
comprendre pourquoi il se positionne
comme ça euh on est là aussi dans une
pensée religieuse c'est-à-dire que le
jugement il vient are tombe
et j'ai tendance à penser que il fait le
choix justement de ne pas critiquer
enfin pour préserver l'institution de
couvrir dans une certaine mesure les
différents crimes et par ailleurs c'est
le cas de du du du père Maciel d'gado de
l'envoyer en pénitence en se disant
enfin c'est le apparemment le le SOMUM
de ce qui pouvait exiger de quelqu'un
qui est qui avait été pédophile donc on
voit là pour le coup il y a un souci de
l'institution qui dépasse et là mais un
peu comme dans dans le cas du sida qui
dépasse l'autre éthique c'est le duel
entre deux éthiques une éthique
institutionnelle et une éthique humaine
il a choisi l'éthique institutionnelle
euh Carol votila avait été élu pape en
78 à l'âge de 58
ans son pontificat a duré 27 ans c'est
le 3è plus long pontificat de l'histoire
vaticane vous le placé où dans la
hiérarchie des pontificats il nous reste
une minute
euh c'est un pontificat puis malgré tout
on mararqué l'histoire malgré tout ce
qu'on s'est dit là malgré le contenu de
de ce documentaire oui c'est un
pontificat majeur alors est qu'il faut
amener un bémol bah il faut toujours
faut toujours nuancer c'est la pensée
même de le travail même de l'historien
c'est un pontificat majeur moi je ne le
vois pas comme le triomphe de de la
réaction hein très franchement je le
vois contraire comme un pontificat
d'équilibre notamment au milieu de la
très grave crise que traverse l'Église
catholique depuis Vatican I qui a
fracturé le monde catholique entre
partisan et du concile et opposant du
concile entre ceux qui veulent aller
plus loin de ce qui a déjà amorcé le
concile et ceux qui veulent au contraire
revenir à une situation antérieure et
lui il se place à mon avis entre entre
les deux et cet équilibre on le trouve
dans tous les domaines aussi bien
diplomatique que religieux vous avez le
mot de la
fin 20 secondes vous le placez où ce
pontificat trème plus long pontificat de
l'histoire moi je je je moi je pense que
c'est plutôt un échec effectivement
parce que la stratégie de reconquête de
de de de de solidification de l'Église
catholique en l'occurrence ça c'est un
c'est un échec euh moi je pense qu'il
faut relativiser quand même je veux dire
la la la la lutte contre le communisme
s'il n'y avait pas eu la lutte des
Polonais est-ce que Jean-Paul II aurait
fait tomber tout enfin voilà le le rôle
de Jean-Paul i c'est de soutenir la
lutte des des Polonais mais ce qui
compte d'abord c'est la lutte des c'est
la lutte des Polonais et et
effectivement il n'anticipe pas cette
crise majeure qui est celle des des des
des des violences sexuelles dans
l'Église catholique
90 % des Polonais étaient catholique à
l'époque de l'élection de Jean-Paul II
voilà un élément pour euh euh aller
au-delà de de votre réponse merci un
grand merci à tous les trois hein
d'avoir participé à cette émission
débadoc pour parler de de ce pontificat
de de Jean-Paul II avec ce documentaire
tiré de la la série les coulisses de
l'histoire vos réactions ça ça sera sur
hashtagdbadog merci aussi à selmaali et
sarudeline qui m'ont aidé à préparer
cette émission et je vous retrouverai
quant à moi pour un prochain débat doc
ça sera la même place à la même heure et
toujours avec son documentaire et son
débat à
[Musique]
bientôt